Menstrual hygiene
is a very, very taboo job in our area.
I mean, you cannot talk to the men
about the menstrual periods
or any kind of issue.
Maya Vishwakarma, thank you so much
for joining me on my show.
How are you?
I'm really great.
I'm doing good.
It's beautiful here in California.
So, yeah.
It's nice, yeah.
Thank you so much
for joining me all the way
from California.
But really, what we'll talk about
is not California.
We're going to talk
about India today, right.
Because you're doing
some fascinating work
with India and helping a lot of people,
both locally and at scale.
So, I want to just dive straight into it.
Maya, tell me a little bit
about your journey
and how do you get
to work in rural Indian,
helping a lot of women?
Yes.
So, Michael, I am born
and brought up in India.
It's a very small village
called Mehragaon,
and it's like you can't even find
in the Google map.
And that's where I grew up.
And I came all the way from there
to the United States.
And then I study science.
And then I was doing
my PhD program in South Dakota.
After two years, I dropped it
and I joined the research here.
And one thing I realized,
like how many people comes from
that far to here and pursue the study
and have a good life.
And the things I've seen
in my village, back in my village
and problems are arising.
So, I thought, like,
let's give some try
and, you know,
just serve those people.
So, I went back to my village,
search of all the problems,
I knew also because I grew up there.
So, then I find out, like, okay,
these are the bigger issues which I can,
you know, work easily
because nothing is like,
difficult for me
since I know the people,
language and culture and everything.
So, then I started
with this project called
menstrual hygiene awareness
affordability and availability.
These three things like,
it has to be there
because in the remote area everywhere,
this is the women hygiene,
women hygiene is a big issue everywhere,
most of the part.
So, tell me a little bit
about this big issue.
What is the issue
and what is the scale of it as well?
Because, you know,
coming from a place
that's a little far away,
it's a little distant
from my understanding.
So, share with me a little bit
about what's actually happening.
Yes.
So, the thing is, like earlier time,
like, if you talk
about like our grandmas time,
that time, they were like,
you know, very, very
accu with the cotton clothes.
We all know, like, you know,
all the time,
the women they used to have
the good cotton in the abundance
that they can change
that cloth every time they can dry.
And they had that kind of a freedom.
But over the time
we replaced that cotton
with the synthetic,
with the other materials
and then families getting divided
and then the women space
got very, very small.
And now, the new modern India
so-called like the
architecture of the houses,
the buildings that are build,
you can't dry that clothes in a sun.
And it is a big taboo in India.
So, if you can't dry
and you can't wash that clothes,
then ultimately, it will be
making you sick.
And nowadays it's very, very hard
because one woman is using
the same clothes over
and over and over and over.
And especially in the rainy season,
it gets really moisture
and that's how they got UTI,
URTI, cervical cancer
and so many of those stuff.
So, this is the major issue.
And because of
the biggest population in India,
like we are billions in India,
so, it's a hard to reach out
the sanitary pad to each and everyone
in the remote, in the tribal area.
So, most of the women
who are living in the outside,
like outskirt countryside,
they don't even know
what is sanitary pad.
And if they know the sanitary pad,
it is so expensive
that they can't even afford it.
Because it comes with a,
it doesn't come with the livelihood
because they had
to arrange first the food,
and then only
they can think about other stuff.
So, most of the population
can't afford such expensive pads.
And if they can afford then
it's not available there.
So, then we started thinking about it
and then we thought, like,
you know how to solve this problem
in our area, actually.
So, tell me a little bit about
this problem solving thinking.
First of all, how would you define
the scale of this problem?
So, how many people do you think
are lacking this proper hygiene
or sanitation right now,
because of these different norms
in modern India?
How big is this problem
that you're tackling?
So, the problem is really, really huge.
The data says like
still in the modern age
in India, all the rural place,
70% population is still not getting
the hygienic stuff.
Wow.
70% in the village in the rural India,
they are not getting the sanitary pad
or any hygienic stuff.
So, the problem is very, very big,
very, very high.
And I tell you, like 12% girls,
they drop out because of this issue.
Because in the school,
when they get to periods,
they don't have pads.
They use the clothes
and then they go to school
and the school doesn't have toilets,
and, you know, comfort kind of place
where they can change.
So, they don't go to school.
And then finally, they drop out.
So, 12% girls
they drop out from the school
because of the sanitary pad.
Unbelievable.
And so, tell me a little bit
about your experience.
How do you even get involved
with thinking about a problem like this
and knowing that this is something
that you're passionate about solving?
Yeah, because this relate
to my own story.
When I was growing up in those areas,
I was also one of them in my teens,.
So, in my high school.
I also feel the similar issues,
like using the clothes,
and very hard time for drying them.
And if they dry it's hard to keep them
like six hours or so.
So, all these difficulties,
I went through.
And then, you know,
over the time, I also got some
kind of infections
and all issues like the other women's.
And then because I was always
a ward in a hospital
in the medical research.
So, I thought,
I may can solve these issues
because this relate to me.
This is my very, very intimate,
you know, issue that I can understand
other girls, other women.
So, then I went there
and then I talked to the women's
and heard their issues,
their problems.
And then we thought, like, okay,
how can we go one by one,
one step at the time.
Then we find out, like,
you know, who is the guy,
I mean, who's the guy
working on these issues.
Then I travel all over India,
find out some people.
And one of them is like,
Arunachalam Muruganantham,
he's the guy
who's biopic is very, very famous.
It's called Pad Man.
So, it is like one of the big
blockbuster in India.
So, that guy I met
and he was kind of inspirational.
And then I started arranging machines
the materials and the women's
and the trainings
and scalabilities and everything.
So, it's around like
six, seven years journey, yeah.
So, you're saying it as if
it's a very, very simple.
Yes, scalability, and that everything,
but I would love to hear that story.
Because I think that's really
where it gets fascinating,
how you can actually
take this idea, take this poll
and bring it to fruition
and create a product that actually makes
such a strong impact,
especially in a population
where it's not the same thing
as creating a product
and marketing it to a bunch of consumers
right in the United States.
It's a different type of problem,
it's a different type of distribution.
So, tell me first a little bit about
the solution that you found,
and then I would love
to really talk about the distribution
and the scalability of it.
How do you get it
to all these women?
Because it's again,
it's a very different industry
from those that I'm used to.
Yes. So, it is completely different
because it's a hygiene kind of industry.
And very few people work
for that issues
because all the multi company
come forward
and then they take over this.
But the problem is, first of all,
in our area, it's like agricultural area.
And the income
of the poor family capital
is very, very less.
And they mostly spend in like,
you know, food
and arranging other stuff.
So, the women hygiene comes
at the very last end.
Like here in the United States,
we live here,
we include the sanity pad
and all the hygiene stuff
in our monthly budget.
So, we buy at the same time like,
you know, when we
are buying our groceries
or vegetables or other things,
but not in India.
It's not even considered
like it is a things to buy.
So the thing is like, when the women,
they are not getting on the time,
they are not educated,
they are not aware, we didn't had
any kind of syllabus in our book
right up to 10th grade
that the hygiene should be,
you know, included.
And this is the prominent issues
and all the girls,
they should learn about
this thing in a school.
So, this is like really big issues
in our community.
So, then what I thought, like,
okay, how difficult it is. Right?
Because I'm already working
in a science side
and medical side and other stuff.
That time I was working in UCSF.
So, then I spoke to the local people
like how big this taboo is.
And it is a big taboo
because nobody wants to talk
about this problem.
So, first thing, you are a local
and you need to talk to the people
and convince them
that like, I really want to work
on this issues in this area only.
Because I can work anywhere in India.
But why I chose my own district,
location, hometown area?
Because I understand people
and I want to solve that problem
from that community.
So, then we arrange the machines
and then, you know,
the material which comes all the way
from China, as we all know,
like it's all standard.
And then we find out
the good machines
and we hired the women
who are actually looking for a job.
They are like a daily worker,
the daily wage worker.
Amazing.
Yeah. So, we hired them.
We train them
what is a hygiene,
how to make sanity pads.
But it's a very small scale
that we were working earlier.
But then slowly,
we gave them confidence
like, hey, this is your product,
you are going to work here,
and we gave the brand
this called No Tension sanitary pad.
And they got like very happy like,
hey, this is our own products
we are making
and we are distributing.
So, then that gets like really, really
around the cities
and then the villages.
And then we reach out
to the more women.
Because in India
the sector is divided.
Like the men's,
they work in a different parts
and the women,
they work in a different work.
It's like the industry side,
you will find the more men
and the less women.
But in agriculture,
there is like 50%, 50-50.
And then there are some certain groups
in all the villages like
ASHA karykarta workers, those groups,
they are only for the women.
So, the women to women
it's easy to spread out the word,
spread out the products.
And after that,
after manufacturing the pad,
then I thought like maybe
the education is
the most important key
to, you know, educate them
about the awareness,
how to use pads,
how to dispose the pad.
Because the environmental issue
is also coming up in landfilling
and plastics and all that.
So, we need to approach
in a holistic way
where we are giving the solution
also, we are giving the
other solution to dispose
the sanitary pad.
Because in India
we don't have like, you know,
things like separation
and segregations and all that.
We dump at the one place
or we burn at the one place.
So, this is how
this was very critical because, you know,
the awareness and the education part.
So, I took the place
that I will go around that area
and stay on the road for, like,
you know, a couple of months
and educate all the schools
and the girls hostel
and the Tivoli in terms
of the menstrual hygiene,
like the awareness program.
So, we designed the program,
we designed the material.
And then I went to 15 tribal area,
stayed there for a few days,
and then, you know,
take the workshop and the conferences
and the classes in all,
you know, girl kind of a hostel.
So, you can meet like larger population
from a different villages,
you train all the girls,
like how to spread this message,
how to reach out
to other women in your village.
Very, very cool.
Exactly.
So, this program
went like really very, very successful
and all the media is covered.
And it came in the local news
so that other people also
they were reading.
And this was kind of eye openers.
And that time the movie
was coming like Pad Man.
So, eventually my name
came up as a pad woman of India.
So, this was the time
where I spent most of the time
on the road,
and then I spread out like,
you know, I reach out
to thousands of girls,
women's need it.
They had millions of questions
like, hey, why this happens,
why that happens and so many.
And unfortunately,
there's no system where
they can ask their queries
and they can get the right answer
and they can study well.
Because, you know,
when you have something in your mind
and you are not getting answers on time,
then you cannot focus on your study
or in your daily day-to-day life.
So, this is how like, you know,
we spread out this awareness programs
and the sanitary pads
all over the places.
I think that's just remarkable.
Tell me a little bit about
the most difficult thing
that you've encountered
throughout this process.
Because you make it
sound relatively okay.
But I'm sure that
it was incredibly difficult.
I mean, you're talking about
having to find a holistic approach
to solving an incredible need
within the country
that has billions of people,
and you're talking about something
with a population
that doesn't necessarily
have also the funds
and education to start with.
So, I'd love to hear a little bit about
the greatest challenges
that you've had along the way.
Yeah. So, the challenges is like I mean,
if I were work in San Francisco,
I have an excellent like,
you know, teams I can find,
I can hire people,
I can get the best of the best,
you know, talent there.
But when you when you go
to the grassroots level,
work in a very, very like,
you know, deep into interior,
you had a very hard time to find
a suitable person for the suitable job.
So, this was my biggest challenge,
that I cannot find the accountant,
I cannot find a computer guy,
I cannot find a data entry
because you are living with nothing.
There's no I mean, hardly electricity.
And you have challenges
like network and so many things.
So, getting the right team
on the right time,
understanding, you know,
they would understand your issue
and you would understand their issue,
it's a difficult part.
And then other difficult one
was because menstrual hygiene
is a very, very taboo job in our area.
I mean, you cannot talk to the men
about the menstrual periods
or any kind of issue.
Convincing them, telling them,
hey, this is your family,
so this is your maybe mom issues,
sister issues, wife issues,
you know, we need to speak up about it.
And then sometimes they get like,
you know, they hide,
they just, you know, feel shy.
And even the women also
they feel very shy.
Like if you if you go to the room
and where 10, 20 women are sitting
and you start speaking about the period,
they will go away.
So, you cannot do that.
You have to relate with something
to something to something
and then you come up
on the on the real talk
like the periods
and other sort of issues.
Because it's a very, very big taboo.
And fighting on that is like it's a hard.
So, these kind of issues I faced
in the beginning,
but when you open about yourself,
you train like women
and then 10 people other,
they are speaking with you
with the same issue,
then people will believe.
Like, hey, this is something
that we really need to listen,
this is something we really need to talk.
So, these are the issues which I go,
and I'm still facing the challenges
to get the right team,
to get the right people
for my job in this scalability
is very difficult.
So, slowly we are training people slowly,
slowly we are involving.
Right.
So, then, you know, things will improve.
I know it will be
a never ending challenge for us, yeah.
Unbelievable.
Maya, I have to say that
it's inspiring to hear
the both the challenges,
but also you know,
that the incredible work
that you're doing over there.
I think it's incredibly innovative.
And to me personally,
it's inspiring to see somebody
who goes after such an important topic
from the get go.
And I want to thank you
for being so generous with your time
in the past 20 minutes.
I'd love for you to share with me
three words that you would use
to describe yourself.
So, in three words,
I can say that I'm very fearless,
very confident and very,
I would say the learner for a lifetime.
So, these are the three words
which I want to conclude this.
Amazing.
Maya, thank you very, very much.
This was wonderful.
Continue making such a positive impact.
And stay safe and stay healthy.
Yeah, you too.
Thank you so much.
Happy holidays
and happy New Year in advance.